[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
what is it this today uh halloween kills
honest trailer commentaries yeah a
spooky a halloween season on his trailer
uh i'm here with lon harris we're giving
you all the behind the scenes thoughts
uh the cut scenes rather the scenes that
have been slashed from the final cut
uh we're gonna be doing some viewer
comments and questions we'll tease you
with next week's honest trailer we're
gonna go through this one frame by frame
and give you all of our most
deepest darkest uh thoughts and feelings
about this film uh a film that we were
talking before we started rolling it
tries to be a little deeper than i think
it succeeds in being asking questions
like uh is it uh is it the true demonic
manifestation of evil we should be
worried about or mob justice hmm you be
the judge lawn which is it what should
we be worried about michael demons or or
uh the ignorance of crowds i mean i'm
i'm definitely on the on the record of
saying i think the fact that every
horror or monster thing ends up becoming
like you know who the real monster is
man
we are the real monsters and like like i
get that every once in a while that
would be the theme or like that's an
interesting twist but it's like that's
always the theme and i feel like it's
we're doing that again and that's that's
just not like i don't need a halloween
film to be about
something else like
grief or trauma or
you know mob justice and vigilantism or
whatever like halloween films are
already about a thing
look out he has a knife
look out look at the guy's in a mask and
he's got uh he's gonna kill us well yeah
this has certainly gotten a mixed uh
reception uh critically and i guess
online or whatever and i look i'm not a
horror fan frankly i mean i like i
probably like well then well here i will
say i like about two horror films a year
and don't care for every
other one um so i guess i all right i
wouldn't call myself a fan but like i
think the cream rises to the top but
this to me is like what horror fans want
which to me is like a conveyor belt of
cool kill sequences and i feel like this
movie gave me that it's it's missing the
the fun like this movie is dour and self
serious and those movies that are
splatter fests where it's just like
jason ripping through teens at camp
they're fun because they allow us to
have fun with it like it's gory and
violent but in a silly way in a
cartoonish way in a goofy way in a way
that we know that is like sort of safe
and silly and that's the fun of a lot of
these kind of horror movies is it takes
something that really does scare people
the idea of being chased through the
woods by a stranger who's trying to
murder you it's like a primal thing but
in a way that feels safe and at a
distance that we can enjoy communally
and i think this movie really forgets
that and it's like really serious and
grim and dour and wants you to feel like
the consequences and repercussions of
violence but that's exactly what you
don't want when you're enjoying michael
squeezing a guy's eyeballs out with his
thumbs or well i would say someone
against a lot more of the latter than
the former like to me they they kind of
bring up those uh
heavier themes and then they just kind
of don't uh
explore them or they resolve them in a
very you know facile just quick way like
the the hospital sequence i think is the
big moral moment of the film but
something that's that you brought up
like that it should be just kind of fun
and escapist uh uh
to watch the slasher rampage through
town and we we were talking about this
did make it into the trailer about how
they've chosen to kind of do the inverse
of the usual uh
uh
filler
uh body count type characters where they
usually make them kind of despicable and
you're rooting against them but in these
in the halloween reboots they make them
like quirky and lovable so when michael
myers finally kills them it feels just
like
i don't know it feels extra mean it made
it hard for me to root for michael myers
killing these people whereas other
horror movies i find like oh good that
was the that was the jock that was an
[ __ ] or oh that's all
it wasn't a virgin so she deserves to
die by by horror movie logic like
there's
they broke the rules in that way and i
don't know if it worked for me
yeah i mean i feel like these movies
they're always it should be like funny
or scary like some that's the that's the
sort of the spectrum that you're on you
know some of them lean more towards
being silly goofy about the jason x's of
the world and then some of them lean
more towards being intense and scary the
the texas chainsaw massacres the
original halloween scream kind of
perfectly finds that balance in between
where it's some scenes are really
intense and some scenes are groovy this
it's like not even on that spectrum it's
on the like sad to thoughtful spectrum
and it's like i don't i don't want to be
sad or thoughtful except for the the uh
michael my slasher the michael myers
trick shot montages which again i think
are at least 40 of the film are are like
long shots of of him rampaging which i
think is what the people what the people
want right that's what they come to pay
for and i think that it also i don't
think it works out of context yeah well
the other thing that this film has uh
boatloads of is uh halloween lore and
look i've i watched the the reboot uh
i've seen the original i've i've caught
some of the sequels throughout my life
but there is a cram it you could have
watched the cramming
i'm sure i watched kramen at some point
but i could take you through the whole
series yes you could well i feel like i
needed youtube because they were really
i thought like over emphasizing how
important these characters were to
halloween lore and like the flashback
sequence i was like how much of this was
really in the movie in the first film
and how much are they inserting to
i was a little bit lost as someone who
doesn't go through the halloween lore
every year before i watch it all these
characters really are in the first film
lonnie elam is in there and mary and the
nurse who's in the car with uh dr loomis
like they're they're doing a very good
job of like checking
fandom.com wikis and wikipedia and like
connecting all these dots it just it
doesn't feel it doesn't feel
particularly believable like the idea
that
that tommy doyle and lonnie elam and the
nurse who was in dr loomis's car our
drinking buddies now is like
pretty freaking out there to me like
it's just like it doesn't feel necessary
and i just the entire idea of the first
movie is that haddonfield is like any
town usa like it's not special
it's just this normal suburban community
and that's why this is so scary because
it can happen anywhere you know and the
more we dig into like learning the
street grid of haddonfield and learning
who lives in every house and making
every location so important and iconic
and revisiting that one night over and
over again it just imbues it with this
importance that it's not supposed to
have well but you need him to be a demon
uh baby at this point because like why
hasn't he died yet and we need to make
sequels and this is very clearly part
two of a
three plus movie uh franchise that
they're yeah this is we were saying this
is like episode eight to ten of the
netflix season where it's the 13th
episode season they're just like all
right just get through it listen maybe
daredevil has some meetings i don't know
we got to fill these episodes
all right let's watch you guys trailer
for halloween
i iron fist gets a barista gig i don't
know
[Music]
the franchise that's been rebooted more
times than lieutenant dangle has
returned new boot goofing
into an honest trailer it's it's been
too long i know we've referenced
lieutenant dangle before at some point
yes um i think we've even referenced new
boot goofy really okay yeah joe's a fan
as well i think joe had a couple yeah
[Music]
classic big classic show classy
character yeah uh
reno 911.
uh the one thing we're watching my
channel yeah now i'm roku check it out
all right uh keep playing and after
making a killing in theaters one thing
is for sure
people would rather get covered than
sign up for peacock
halloween kills
you thrilled as the strodes faced off
against michael myers now get ready to
see what literally everyone else in town
was up to that night from dr loomis's
nurse to the kid laura used to babysit
to the kid laurie's friend used to
babysit it's funny that they all uh
got the original actors back except uh
is it michael c hall what's his name
michael
the oh anthony alcohol anthony michael
yeah
except one of them grew what's what's
that original actor saying like hey i
don't know but also that character is
played by paul rudd in halloween six so
you have to wonder at some point did
they think about maybe getting paul rudd
for this uh i'm sure that they did i
wonder must have been thrown around in a
meeting or two like oh you know we
should get because where they're they're
eliminating halloween six from the
cannon like that didn't but they're
referencing the other movies in this
anyway so why not i can't see paul rudd
in that i did my own research uh no
facebook
i'll step out of character and praise
the film for a moment that's good
casting like he really nails this he's
very believable as a guy who you believe
has the county with the greatest
yeah yeah he's definitely got some
ivermectin in the medicine cabinet
keep playing to the kid they used to
bully the kid that laura used to babysit
all of haddenfield will band together to
reminisce about that five minutes of
scream time they got 40 years ago 40
years ago a madman escaped from a mental
hospital he killed my daughter 40 years
ago he's infected my family with grief
and fear for 40 years michael myers has
haunted this town for 40 years 40 years
ago when i was a kid you protected me
michael myers has returned awesome
two things one h4o why not go with that
if you're going to bring up the 40-year
thing all the time i don't understand
why it seems like that would be an
obvious uh touchstone to go with this
but here's my other thing what is go it
is a
is a small town bar halloween night
talent show where people also give
dramatic speeches a thing that i'm just
like from the city and don't know about
because that seems ridiculous i mean
it's a shallow talent pool it's like you
know there's only so many folks and oh
here comes the one with the
ventriloquist dummy
even a bar i don't think i've ever been
to a bar where there was just a like
there's open mics but i don't know if
i've ever been to an organized talent
show but why on halloween night
well be weird if it was on christmas in
this movie it's just such a it's such a
like
contrivance like you've never gone out
today you're seeing all these characters
here we want tommy to give this speech
to a bunch of people and it's just like
thrown like i don't i didn't believe
that i think telling spooky stories is a
talent and i think that i would rather
watch that than a ventriloquist
uh
it was it wasn't even i don't even know
it's like a it's like a it's like an
evil ted talk
you didn't really need that on that on
top of it it could have just been like
every halloween they get together and
have drinks at this bar and this i think
it actually would probably work better
if you were just at that table or
counter with them they worked it into a
conversation you'd also get to know
those characters better i i feel like
that was that was probably a very
different movie but you know like i said
only watch so many horror films but uh
you ever see vfw
oh yeah with the old guy though right
that was cool man
yeah yeah yeah that was good
anyways random movie ring all right keep
playing
extra crispy he'll pick up right where
he left off mindlessly killing people
then very mindfully arranging their
bodies in an artful tableau
hmm it's missing a certain genesecua
perhaps one more knife right
there and the only thing that's up on
his path so he's just on a
b line like a to b
um
to his childhood home right that's what
we learn in this film and like he has
nothing
no special connection with laurie strode
right right there they made it they're
treating it kind of like a twist yeah in
the first movie
there was we there was this kind of
assumption that michael was going to
come for laurie like the podcasters were
really planning that idea uh and then
yeah this one we kind of come full
circle and it's like he doesn't care
about anyone here but i feel like the
twist should have been the other way
it's like something that adds motivation
to him not like subtracts he's just
trying to get to his house so if the
if the john's left the house he'd be
he'd just live there
the the
the second half of this movie is so
muddled i'm really not even sure what
they're trying to say about michael he's
he's either a manifestation of the
violence within all of us
or he's some sort of undead
ghoul
or like i don't i don't know what his
nature is or what he's supposed to even
represent at this point uh it's it's
they're getting almost close to like
cult of thorn territory from like the
late sequels like he's sub-saharan is he
is he is there druid stuff we're gonna
introduce soon on a long enough timeline
everything becomes everything
yeah ancient druid rituals
uh yeah i don't know just it's just
really like i don't i don't get i still
after two movies i kind of still don't
get their take yeah on like who michael
myers is and what he's what he's doing
other than just like walking around
killing this one i hate to say it it's
ted character beats it's the last jedi
of the halloween trilogy because it's
just not connecting to the first one but
you can tell that the third one is going
to pick up where the first one left off
and just kind of ignore everything that
just happened
like i have a fascinating guys
somehow loomis returned
and he and michael kiss
and everyone's redeemed
all right keep playing
the only thing standing in his path is
franchise star wars lori strode no she
might as well be in a coma okay standing
in the way of mike is alison strode the
next in line to take over the franchise
no she immediately proves she isn't
worthy
okay standing in the way of mike is
karen strode who finally realized her
mom was right and became the badass she
was raised to become no she's still
trying to calm things down
wow i just think it's just
i i i was going to say criminal but
that's too strong it's just a weird
choice to not center this movie around
jamie lee curtis while we have her
but she's so so clearly the best part of
the last film and even the the the
moments she's in this film and it's like
she's game she's ready to fight like you
build the story
from the marketing and the fan response
that that's what had people excited
about this whole new take on halloween
was all right jamie lee curtis and we're
doing we're doing the linda hamilton and
terminator 2 like she's a badass now and
she's going to turn people like that's
what people want to see and yeah having
her in a bed talking to will patton the
whole time it's just like
these are two great character actors no
no no argument for me i enjoy both of
them but like come on give her give her
something fun yeah if you make her
if you make her the lead in this film
and kill her off at the end and then
you're really passing the torch to the
to the next generation but now it's just
it's going to be this weird two-hander
of like it's it's going to be jamie
curtis and allison strode like
dual heroines because you know you need
in the third one them to all face off so
sure of course i i i also feel like
they've done a weird thing like both the
2018 one and this one end
like with the fake out like there's
gonna be this cool heroic beat for judy
greer and that she's going to kind of
become the the the standout heroine
final girl woman of this franchise right
and then they kind of pull back at the
end like she had you know there was that
big reveal like she's actually a great
shot and like she's the one who nails
michael in the head yeah and then this
one where she leads the him to the mob
and you're like all right like big judy
hero moment but then if they mute it and
they under they undermine it both times
yeah you'd think that given where she
ended the last film and the fact that
this film picks up
at the same time later moments later
that she'd still be in the mode of oh
[ __ ] my mom was right right this is a
demonic thing coming to kill us let's
and that's what i really wanted but you
know she's right back to where she was
at the beginning of the 2018 what was
like oh god oh no we gotta hide we gotta
run don't don't upset mom yeah
make sure she stays uh stays calm anyway
uh okay call your grandmother only by
the formal title grandmother at all
times that's how we do it in this family
no grammy or anything maybe it's an
illinois thing who knows they even
signed did you see that she even sized
the card like i love you grandmother
grandmother right that must have stood
out why are you doing this that's the
most horrific thing of all uh okay
wow okay standing in the way of mike are
two gay pirates and an elderly couple
with a drone cool because this was
clearly the middle part of a trilogy and
this killer is craving some filler for
halloween do you know what happens to
people who come into the myers home
without an invitation we're not even
scared he stabbed his sister in the tit
you were impressed
confused to learn danny mcbride up write
these reboots but it takes someone like
kenny powers to write characters this
stupid
as all of haddonfield fights back on
halloween night in the dumbest ways
possible whether they're splitting into
smaller and smaller groups
okay so the key is we stick together now
i'm going in alone what falling for the
same tricks they did 40 years ago us
mistaken um i'm now i'm actually scared
because i'm realizing i think we cut the
part where everybody says evil dies
tonight but it's fine other people have
made that joke a million times um i
think we all kind of and honestly that
like i don't think that is like a major
criticism like it's definitely a thing
that they purposefully say over and over
again but that does kind of feel like a
throwback horror movie sort of
thing i didn't i didn't mind that so
much i mean it was
it it speaks to a movie of a certain
tone that it didn't keep throughout the
whole thing but it's like if this was
if this entire movie was that movie i
would be
where if it was like about tommy doyle
raised in a posse to go kill my minds
and they were all chatting evil guys
tonight and the killers were super gross
and over the top that's a movie i would
once
i think so yeah because it was funny and
fun the degree to which people were
ready to throw down on halloween night
and you know yeah i guess like with an
iron we think you had to make a joke
about that and like right a baseball bat
so like that and that is
they've sort of explored that i think
halloween four there's also like a posse
that comes to kill michael myers but at
least that's like a fun take like even
though it doesn't make sense because in
the world of this film like this all
happened 40 years ago and it's been
peaceful i assume ever since so the idea
that people were like so fed up and it's
like no not what evil does tonight like
you've been fine for 40 years
most of
but yeah they were just really drunk and
uh wanted to
i'll bet they didn't even know what they
were talking about they just said yeah
evil last night brother well that
podcast never came out they never got to
finish their podcast so a lot of people
never got to hear this story
yeah well you know a lot of americans
who probably would have been tipped to
the michael myers saga if only he had
allowed i'm sure npr like found found
the tapes
that made it extra chilly well they were
still as of the action of this movie
they were murdered mere hours before oh
yeah that's good stupidly stupidly they
were planning to make a michael myers
podcast that would come out
after the anniversary of the killings
that was not a good they were very far
back they really needed somebody from
wondering to give them a call and be
like that's not how we do it
gonna go a month ahead
keep coming mistaking a danny devito
look alike for michael myers even though
they all grew up with him and his face
is on the news
it's not him and showing up to a
climactic beatdown in their pj's look
that guy brought a hockey stick who
plays cricket in haddonfield illinois
they're going with a clothes iron where
are all of your guns i thought this was
america and you're just gonna leave him
there i'm gonna chop him into pieces or
blow the body up like a beach whale he's
just gonna get up again
see what did i just say how drunk are
you people prepare yourself for a film
with a message our remorseless serial
killers what we should be worried about
or is forming a mob to stop them the
real evil and like the former
duh
moving on
so enjoy a muddled new installment
it's just
if the
they needed to do
better with like having the mob be out
of control i feel like didn't they do
this a similar thing in halloween two
where the mob actually like kills
somebody or
something like that right and not only
two there i mean
there is an accidental death of the guy
who's in a michael myers mask but yeah i
don't think it's like purposeful
vengeance and they just really seemed to
back off of having
of like actually making the case at all
that that this mob was was on par in any
way shape or form with with the demon
it's also it's just like
in real life if you were like is a
rounding up a posse to go kill somebody
that you think is a murderer or the
right thing to do i think most people
would agree no it is not but in the
reality of a halloween movie knowing
what we in the audience all know about
michael myers like well there's ever
going to be an exception to that rule
like it it's hard to play a halloween
movie like the characters aren't
justified in trying to kill michael
myers because it's literally the only
way to stop him like obviously you can't
arrest this guy he's john wicking like
crews of 20 firemen at once like the
only way to save themselves is to kill
him so it's a weird choice to make your
brave stand against mob you're like
normally yes of course i agree with you
like you call the cops they're like you
know don't don't go hunt somebody down
and kill them but well and then you have
to in this movie they don't really sell
me on it's like no kill michael myers
feel free being charitable though like
the theme from the first film was how
like trauma is passed down through
generations uh specifically the strodes
that through this family and then you
could say that the second film was
trying to do that with like the whole
town but they just weren't that
traumatized by i mean they were 40 years
ago but they didn't make the case for
like he's been haunting this whole town
and it's been so intolerable they
finally snapped
they've they've
flirted in the past in this series with
well maybe the michael myers curse gets
passed down like maybe michael myers is
a killer and then jamie lloyd becomes a
killer she inherits the evil gene or
whatever and like that would work that
that's a metaphor for how evil passes
and the the traumatized become the
traumatizers and whatever and i think
you could do something like that
but they don't want they don't want to
make jamie lee curtis or judy greer evil
like it's more fun to just keep it being
like the big iconic guy we all know uh
so you're stuck with this muddled kind
of in the middle metaphor where it's
like what i just don't know what michael
myers represents it's like
the pure evil or the evil that's within
all of us or the wave
i hope they wrote like the first film
and the last film together and they're
like look we just need to kind of keep
things the same and just kill some time
until we get to the last one because i
hope they know where they're going with
this the next is definitely andy
manichak flying to a planet of michael
myers
she's gotta locate the the piece to find
the stone to get the arrow that'll tell
her where to go
find the key finder to go to the planet
of michael myers and absorb all of their
power all their power maybe it's like
the ending of uh uh the one jedley's
film the one where it's it's a planet
michael myers with a motorcycle yeah um
and it's just michael myers fighting a
planet also full of michael myers um i
mean what this would be
background
now you've got a pitch now you're
pitching yourself
all right keep going that tries to
strike a balance between the old-school
scares of the slasher genre
the self-aware comedy of the current era
michael meyer
go look go look hell no a little bit of
john wick
and social commentary usually reserved
for jordan peele or an a24 film about a
goat that stands for a miscarriage or
whatever it may not be perfect but it's
still a perfect example of a nostalgia
fueled sequel to a reboot made to erase
bad sequels that itself was a reboot of
the sequels they got rebooted to a race
in the first place and my nose is
bleeding again great
starring
the shove
this new move
a karen
ally mcsqueal i did my own research
lonnie
jenkins
uh
he's up there with uh
best fictional characters named lon are
there any others there's very few but
it's very the the one other one is uh
the lead character i believe it's colin
hanks in orange county you remember that
movie
i think those are the only two movies i
can think of
all right well the the door's wide open
for you on let's let's get you cast you
know you sound like veteran horror icon
lon chaney but he's a real guy
ah yes yes
uh all right keep going officer involved
rebooting the real housewives of
haddonfield
the speed school of hostage negotiation
better cameo saul
and paula wieners
this is 40 years ago when michael myers
killed my family
the actual coolest part of this movie
realistic donald pleasance prosthetics
wow say that three times fast donald
presents prosthetics donald please
prosthetics donald pleasance prosthetics
this is done john
um yeah she's amazing that that mass
thing i i just assumed it was a really
good one of those digital recreation
jobs no i thought the flashback was
actually really well done at least from
like a film filmic perspective it really
did look like they had gone back in time
uh yeah to make that that was pretty
cool yeah this movie this movie looks
pretty good it does not really look like
a halloween
movie but it does look cool like it has
its own kind of visual style that i
enjoyed yeah i think it was in line with
the with the 2018 one right once you're
at it yeah
exactly i also i would take issue uh we
very quickly showed during the montage
when john's talking about
bad sequels and and remakes and reboots
we show the rob zombie films in there
and i actually like the rap zombie so i
thought that i haven't seen those are
they i would just put those out there i
i think they're kind of disliked though
correct they are oh they're very wide
i'm i'm i'm
yeah this counts as a hot take i think
okay uh but no i won't because i was
just going to say i like those better
than the david gordon green reimaginings
because
uh those are he's trying to make it
scary and like i get that that doesn't
like he's it's very deliberately like
not campy not silly not like there are
references to the original in that he's
sort of remaking it but it's not one of
those like jab you in the ribs like ah
we get right that's the guy for the
first one it's it's trying to make
michael myers different enough that it's
like unsettling again and i i like that
about it
make michael myers unsettling again you
heard it here first yeah um we have some
uh i'm making hats let's watch some
deleted scenes four years ago when i was
a kid you protected me so tonight i'm
gonna protect you whoa whoa slow down
you're gonna run out of bit parts to
bring back for the sequel their
vendettas must be told
because this was clearly the middle part
of a trilogy and this killer is craving
some filler for halloween because this
is half set up for the finale and half
audition tape for myers to join mortal
kombat 11.
come on finish him finish him finish him
starring
look who's stalking
the killing bloke the babysitter's club
the final granny jamie lee hurton
slay jude
greer street merry christmas you filthy
animal say goodbye to these michael
little orphan alley
ali ship tom doyle rules the bloodfest
club midnight mask patton lost brawl
remember the frightens big little guys
squid game vips dirty john's homophobia
welcome back slaughter
evil dies tonight evil dies tonight evil
dies tonight evil dies tonight
it didn't
so yeah i think the reason uh we we
backed off of that one is uh the joke
was made
simultaneous too you know there's like
things in the ether dan merle tweeted
something very similar and um yeah i
said that you took it with my honest
trailer's notes and then like like
literally a few hours later dan tweeted
the exact almost beat for beat the same
joke and so i was like yeah let's not
use that one people think we ripped off
truly a case of great minds uh thinking
alike so
uh prop props to dan on that one i i
think that i would have liked to use
that somewhere um all right let's do
some uh fan questions let's see um
maybe you can answer this lon uh the
cardola nas what was the last actually
clever twist in a slasher film i'm
blanking on one
oh i mean i actually um i don't know if
this was like chronologically last don't
hold me to this but uh i was just
talking about the friday the 13th remake
you remember that one uh what's the
friend that that one has a cool where
it's like the opening and you think that
you're watching like the whole movie but
then the opening is only like 20 minutes
and then you go back and you see like
the
the main story starts and like that's a
cool misdirection thing i didn't see
coming in in a reinvention of a of a
horror film i also would say the rob
zombie halloweens i think are an
interesting
different take that he really radically
takes off in its own direction
interesting yeah
i mean i don't know if scream even
counts um and like happy death day or is
it is a fun
is a fun tweak on it sure yeah yeah um
oh and happy i would say happy death day
also yeah you know like yeah
um okay let's see uh what monster bad
guy would you like to see fight michael
myers from aaron matthew um like a
freddy versus jason what's uh what's a
good matchup for uh mike myers no
speaking of which uh we did do a london
day massive uh script for the best uh
slasher that's out today uh michael
we're comparing just yeah it's freddy
jason and michael yeah kills escapes
deaths um every on-screen instance of
that to see who comes out on top michael
myers may surprise you uh but like who
who's a good foe for him i mean
another does it have to be a monster or
bad guy the yakuza let's do the yakuza
yeah i like that yeah i was gonna say
he's got some like limitations like he's
like he can do the like kind of pop up
supernaturally where you don't expect
him and he's like got stealth but he's
not like fast so i feel like you can't
pair him up against somebody who's like
like a john wick is it just too fast
he'll just like yeah you know run
circles around him so you gotta you
gotta think of it in terms of like like
a yakuza where they don't have any
supernatural they're just guys with
swords and guns or like i was gonna say
like a chucky where it's like he's also
got some
limitations just based on size and speed
but it would be like a strategic
match-up yeah those two yeah if he is
like a timeless uh demonic presence
throughout history i think putting him
in like the crusades maybe against king
arthur
i said i'd watch that well merlin i feel
like would make make quick work of of
microbiota it would have to just be like
lancelot and arthur and there's no magic
or something yeah
um
similar death patel as gawain versus
now deviled ham writes uh uh killing
people i kind of like is more horrifying
than killing a bunch of one-dimensional
tropes i don't care about while waiting
for lori strode to show up i would say
these people are still
1.5 dimensional tropes they're just ones
that you like they're just like quirky
kind of cosmopolitan people like that
yeah i think it's a it's a tone it's a
tone thing that just feels off it's not
fun to watch them die because they've
just been
humanoid it bums me out but like that i
don't know that's it that's not what i
it's not what i want i just i i i agree
that the there's there's moments where
it almost feels like they want you to
feel sad during the kills like when that
woman's being forced to watch her
husband get knives repeatedly jammed
into him and it's just like that's not
that's not fun in the way that i that
you i think yeah again you could either
go
chilling disturbing scary or can't be
over the top fun
they're trying to do this this balance
that i don't think works yeah
all right let's close with this from the
reynard city update channel uh what
other special holiday serial killers
should there be in addition to halloween
uh i mean there's so many right it
really is i think harvard's festival
boxing day and bonfire night are those
is that all canadian i don't recognize
any of yes
that's definitely some other country
[Laughter]
we don't celebrate any of those things i
think a canadian serial killer should uh
should have a day like with a razor
uh hockey stick i guess um it's very
hard to not dip immediately into crude
story yeah like it's like it's like
covering serial killer hot poutine yeah
i don't know enough about canada to even
make fun of it uh but yeah what is she
he kills ice fishermen
oh no he's got socialized healthcare
uh yeah what other holidays are left
because there's obviously like there's
christmas there's jack frost of course
or in valentine we've got a we've got my
bloody valentine and there's one that's
just called valentine
yeah we've got the leprechaun for st
patrick's day we apparently got the
leprechaun you know like christmas
slashers is a whole sub genre you've got
your black christmases and silent night
deadly night do we have a hanukkah a
hanukkah killer like eight days
that was gonna be my pitch because the
day thing but there's probably just you
know this it's probably yeah the
specificity i think that's great yeah
you get the timeline built in like oh
it's uh the tension gets ratcheted up
every night and i i think all the kills
you also have to come up with either
they like spin to death or they get lit
on fire or well i think if yeah if the
body gets like i'm gonna kill one person
the first night two the second three the
third and they're gonna get more and
more elaborate and uh right elaborate
and they've all gotta like you know you
got like gold coins have to be involved
in some way you know like let's not go
full trucks
yeah i think you have to go it's gotta
be they're chopped incredibly over the
top
okay yeah let's let's go pancakes until
his stomach bursts well i can't wait to
log off of this and go write the next
great uh jewish exploitation horror
movie with you i think it's a genre
whose time has come um let's see uh
what's what's next week we actually i
actually got a slack so i know we were
trying to uh determine what would be the
i feel like there's two things floating
out there and it could be one or the
other uh we now have that we have
confirmation that it will be one that is
a uh a whole world of possibility will
be okay
so
wait it could be either one that could
be ah that's great yeah come on back uh
coming back next week where you'll find
all the answers to that question and
more on australia commentaries thank you
lon thanks everybody for watching see
you later
[Music]
you